[Music]
happy what's he say hello to héctor mejía and
this is a short briefing in spanish
the city of las vegas is offering
housing rental assistance a
new program offers
rent or mortgage assistance to those who
qualify and can receive up to  three
months of help the deadline to apply is
july 31st this assistance will be
provided on a first come first serve basis
so don't wait until the
last minute
the justice center book is also
helping both landlords and
renters work together during
this time  offers
free mediation services to avoid lawsuits
all landlords and tenants should
work to find a payment plan that
benefits both parties for more
information visit yusnel dotcom
the children's museum download and reopen to the
public today but will do so with some
changes in  their agenda to keep
everyone safe they will limit the number
of people inside this place as well
there will be a
temperature check and you must wear a
mask tickets are now
available online
now moving on to the weather forecast it
will be warmer today however
the winds will continue but they will not be very strong
we will have clear skies and
warm temperatures  they will stay for
the rest of the week for the
weekend the temperatures will exceed
100 degrees have a nice day greetings
to héctor mejía and this was his brief
informative edition in spanish
[Music]